ce chef c'est guillaume cantin vous le
reconnaissez peut-être c'est le gagnant
de la première saison de l'émission les
chefs
depuis le vent il en a fait des choses
mais aujourd'hui un projet qui lui tient
à coeur se concrétise la transforment
nos lives et de laurens a transformé ses
parties de l'esprit qu'on voulait faire
quelque chose pour gaspillage
alimentaire on voulait que ce soit
positif collaboratif c'est vraiment le
travail que les commerçants pour
dimanche matin dans un stationnement du
quartier rosemont la petite patrie
guillaume donné consigne à son équipe
avant le départ pour la collecte des
aliments et vendus dans les épiceries
parfaite de munich
je pense c'est mieux qu'au marie la
coordonnatrice et michel de chauffeurs
bénévoles prennent la route
ils font la tournée des quatre commerces
partenaires pour récupérer les denrées
ouest cheveux comme ça va bien
aujourd'hui
tu me les donne je vais les marques et
passer tous les viandes invendus en fait
qu'on vient récupérer donc tout ce qui
est bien des poissons alors qu'ils sont
sortis des rayons ils sont congelés
immédiatement on ce constat qui nous ont
fourni des glacières pouvoir ensuite les
récupérer
ça c'est fini pour le premier commerce
c'était une belle récolte non boussens
ouais vraiment vraiment oui on a chaque
fois chaque semaine on a un beau temps
qui en a il y en a de plus en plus donc
l'idée de la transforme vie est née d'un
défi lancé à guillaume par son ami soit
de faire un souper gastronomique avec
des déchets on sentait que ça me tentait
pas trop chier comme dit non départ puis
c'est pas du talent des déchets cars
avec lui ils m'ont convaincu puis
vraiment une semaine après en avoir
vraiment les mains dans les poubelles or
les études rosemont petite patrie
si nous a vraiment surpris spots ans la
quantité mais ce concert hier une
quantité mais la qualité des aliments
qu'on veut trouver puis à partir de ce
moment là on s'est dit qu'est ce qu'on
fait avec ça
la mission et nous récupérer pour
redistribuer à des organismes de charité
transformer une partie des aliments les
plus récurrents et aussi aider les
commerçants à réduire le gaspillage
alimentaire
on veut venir et la réduction à la
source à amener des solutions à long
terme pour encore mieux réduire ce qui
est sorti des rayons les invendus
deuxième arrêt dans cet entrepôt
d'épicerie d'autres caisses pleines de
denrées que vous allez pouvoir vraiment
faire quelque chose avec son regard doux
sommet mais ça dans le fond de ce fait
ça arrive de temps en temps qu'on en ait
qui sont un petit peu amoché comme ça
mais vu que nous on les transforme très
rapidement en fait dès qu'on va revenir
à notre espace de tri on va couper les
partis qui sont très abîmées des fruits
vraiment les laver puis on va les mettre
tout de suite dans une chambre froide
fatalement s'était produit oui oui on
est un peu de chaque département je fais
vraiment un suivi régulier avec les
commerçants comment ça se fait qu'il ya
autant de gaspillage on essaie de
trouver des acheteurs ou des cycles pour
voir justement s'il ya des erreurs qui
pourraient être réduites ce si important
pour voir s'il ya des les améliorations
alors suggéré pied implanté avec
[Musique]
troisième avait chili nous au marché
jean talon
la récolte se poursuit malgré la pluie
là on a une caisse inter de poires donc
c'est sûr tu elles sont quand même pas
mal mur il y en a sont très fragiles et
c'est à ce moment là donc ça va pouvoir
faire super bonne partie note de poires
avec ça
honnêtement les quantités qu'on collait
qu'aujourd'hui où c'est 40 à 50% plus
élevé qu'on pensait et que ça nous a
quand même sorti
qu'est ce qui détermine le qu'une fille
est encore bon ou pas bon alors regardez
comme ici celle ci qui est légèrement
flétrissure le dessus c'est sûr que
c'est pas très vendeur est encore bonne
l'a fait mais moi je peux comprendre les
clients au prix où on les vend parce
qu'elles sont très chères en ce moment
les filles qui peut intéresser d'acheter
une fugue que le duo dont le pourtour
est légèrement flétrie alors moi je les
envoie là sont partis ce matin chez
guillaume
une fois la tournée des épiceries
compléter tout est trié classés par
catégories peser calcul et puis notez
cette compilation permet de voir les
aliments le plus souvent gaspillée et
les quantités par commerce au data ça
fait 4 187 kg cette semaine fait c'est
toujours en ce moment quatre commerces
on ne sait toujours entre 450 à 500 kg
quand on pense que dans ce quartier
seulement il y environ une soixantaine
d'épicerie les multiplications par la
tête
j'ai déjà des choses qui se passent qui
sont très bien mais c'est pas tout qui
est rick perry depuis baissé locke et on
se rend compte qu'elle nie miglos castet
qui finissent pas au bon endroit
on retire les plus amoché on enlève les
parties les plus abîmées et de tous ces
aliments récupérer pas plus de 5% de
pertes se retrouve au compostage
cannelle muscade
ensuite dans les cuisines on transforme
les fruits francs tartinades on copie
cuit les poires un sous-pull d'agrumes
sera transformé en marmelade et on
termine la tartinade de pommes à
l'assemblée c'est en fin de compte dépôt
de 150 militants s'est produit tarte aux
pommes
pis la ligne des produits s'appelle les
rescapés anglais mais vraiment un côté
ludique pas les rescapés rappelle
l'esprit le conte de sauver des animaux
ramenés d'épicerie le de gens qui nous
ont aidé le c'est assez incroyable le
sujet du gaspillage alimentaire leur
part puis c'est là que je trouve ça
intéressant s'il approche humaine qu'on
a collaboratif positif ça donne vraiment
le goût aux gens d'en bas qui nous offre
un service auquel on n'avait pas eu
connaissent un mac c'est tout les fans
semaine
et nous ramène des produits qui sont
bons on va être capable de vendre qu'on
est fiers de vendre donc tout les
arguments sont là pour participer une
économie circulaire car dans chaque
commerce reviennent les rescapés
transformé pour être vendus je suis à
lens 8 magasins dont vous allez
retrouver les rescapés bienvenue ou le
voyez comment qu'elle a transformé une
existence qui sont à réaliser notre
mission et je dois le but ultime ça peut
avoir l'air fou mais ce ne peut exister
une certaine manière